I love being outside. Nature is one of my favorite hobbies.
I like to hike, I like to kayak, I like to canoe.
There's one thing that I sure don't like about being outside and that is mosquito bites.
They just love me; they can't get enough of me.
Well, a lot of people might ask the question,...
..."Why does a mosquito bite you in the first place?"
I'm Janice Creneti. I've been teaching environmental science for over 20 years...
...and I'm here to answer the question, "Why do mosquitoes suck blood?"
Well, first of all one thing that's not commonly understood...
...is that it's actually only of the females of the species that are going after your blood.
You see most species of mosquitoes, males and females,...
...when they're just trying to feed themselves,...
...they actually eat nectar, just sort of like a bee.
They have a long tubelike mouth part that's good for sticking into flowers to get pollen,...
...to get nectar out,...
...but the female of the species needs something special when she's going to lay her eggs,...
...and that's what she gets from the human blood.
She needs irons and protein to properly form the eggs and actually be able to lay them.
That's why she has to go after you and me when we're outside enjoying a summer evening.
Now, the thing about mosquitoes is they can also carry disease and that becomes a problem...
...as they're sucking blood from one person and flying over to bite somebody else.
They can even carry diseases in your pets as well.
If your dog has ever gotten heartworm, a mosquito is probably the culprit.
So, watch out for those mosquitoes.
Use insect repellent when you're outside and protect your pets as well.
I'm Janice Creneti and this is "Why Do Mosquitoes Suck Blood".